ils ont tous entendu un cri d'enfant
dans la nuit et on va essayer on va
essayer de aussitôt les responsables de
la crèche prennent les opérations en
main d'abord tenter de rétablir le
courant pour avoir de la lumière
on n'a pas des convertisseurs mais il
n'y arrive pas nous leur proposons alors
d'utiliser le projecteur de notre caméra
on y va avec la lumière et n'a de tintin
et demi vous l'avez localisé au fait de
ce côté là les petits cris proviennent
de l'arrière de la maison où une partie
des deux étages s'est écroulé comme le
baça à pointer du doigt les là on
l'entend plus là il faut cesser de
monter puis plus aulas et sa boîte à
lumière là vient par là 48 heures après
le séisme
l'enfant se trouveraient sous les tonnes
de gravats est soit pour moi d'un des
ses caisses
dis moi ton nom 1
il pleure je l'entends moi oui toutes
ces ruines ne sont qu'un immense château
de cartes
à la moindre erreur un coup de masse
tonné trop fort tout peut s'écrouler sur
l'enfant allez vas-y frappe avec la
masse
à force de creuser une odeur de mort
finit par se dégager des décombres
car dans cette crèche il y à 80 enfants
portés disparus il ya un trou là allez
allez frapper déblayer moi tout ça
allait tirer les gars tirer tirer fort
les petits pleurs s'entendent de mieux
en mieux
cela veut dire que les sauveteurs ne
sont plus très loin de l'enfant
je crois qu'il est là sous mon pied non
il est plutôt derrière toi il est là je
te dis arrêtez les discussions là à les
creuser on n'a plus le temps
ok ok après cinq heures d'efforts les
sauveteurs arrivent enfin atteindre
l'enfant passe en parfait état mais en
bas vas-y doucement un sans papier elle
ne tire pas trop fort on risque de la
blesser
[Musique]
elle s'appelle line vanessa elle a trois
ans et demi elle vient de passer plus de
48 heures sous les décombres
[Applaudissements]
cette petite fille est une miraculée
à part quelques égratignures vanessa
semble en bonne santé mais visiblement
elle est choquée par ce qui vient de lui
arriver
[Musique]
evelyne la fondatrice de la crèche notre
dame de la nativité n'en reviens
toujours pas après une petite toilette
vanessa finira par s'endormir épuisé
[Musique]
trois jours plus tôt voici à quoi
ressemblait la vie en haïti l'un des
pays les plus pauvres du monde
dans le centre de port au prince la
capitale
chacun vaquait à ses occupations sous le
soleil des tropiques au palais
présidentiel tout était calme et sous
contrôle dans la crèche notre dame de la
nativité 167 enfants jouent et
insouciants dans la tente de leur
adoption mardi à 16h53 une première
secousse la plus violente de magnitude 7
et branle tout le pays
elle va durer 48 secondes et sera suivie
de deux autres très importante
l'épicentre se trouve juste à côté de la
capitale port au prince
quelques minutes plus tard un énorme
nuage de poussière recouvre toute la
ville c'est une habitante qui filme
depuis son balcon sur les hauteurs de
port-au-prince petites choses à
elle-même ne revient pas d'être encore
vivante
maintenant il y en a là et bien plus sur
la musique mais on n'a rien au hockey
une fois la poussière dissiper c'est un
spectacle de désolation et de carnage
qui règne dans les rues les rescapés
reste et bt par la violence du choc
[Musique]
à l'image du palais présidentiel la
plupart des bâtiments ne sont plus qu'un
amas de ruines et partout des centaines
des milliers de cadavres que l'on
ramasse à la pelle mécanique pour les
enterrer dans de gigantesques fosses
communes
[Musique]
très vite la communauté internationale
envoie de l'aide des médicaments de la
nourriture de l'eau mais aussi des
sauveteurs et leurs chiens spécialement
dressés
car une course contre la montre a
commencé pour tenter de sauver le
maximum de survivants particulièrement
préoccupante la situation des enfants
cinq jours après le séisme ce sont les
plus vulnérables aux maladies et aux
épidémies dues à ces milliers de
cadavres en décomposition qui menace les
survivants
dans le quartier de fontamara evelyne la
directrice de la crèche et bien
conscientes de ce risque sanitaire
alors même si les conditions sont plus
que précaire on ne relâche pas les
règles d'hygiène même pour les blessés
trois jours après le séisme
la terre continue à trembler même si une
partie de la crèche est encore debout
elle pourrait s'écrouler à tout moment
impossible de retourner y vivre
tout se fait donc dans la rue
comment vous faites pour
l'approvisionnement en eau pour la
collecte va pouvoir
non mais c'est le voisin qui m'a permis
d'avoir un peu d'eau il est là c'est la
solidarité même pour la nourriture pour
les enfants
pour la ligne à et
j'ai fait acheter un peu partout mais
vraiment le moment les magasins l'az est
donc possible
la seule chose qu'elle a pu récupérer
c'est un peu de pain et de graisses pour
faire une mixture de fortune qu'on fait
la paix avec du pain et de l'eau c'est
basique quoi mais ça ne va pas c'est
fait aux enfants parce que moi j'ai
beaucoup fait parler actif depuis le
tremblement de terre
les enfants ont faim ils ne mangent plus
qu'une fois par jour
[Musique]
mais pas de lait pour les enfants j'en
ai mais c'est dans la maison et on ne
peut pas trop y accéder heureusement un
membre de la crèche a été fouillée du
côté des cuisines
regardez ce que je viens de trouver de
l'autre côté de la maison voyez ça c'est
super c'est tombé là en arrière de la
maison et on y voit là juste une dizaine
de boîtes de conserve et quelques
portions de fromage
[Musique]
pas de quoi nourrir toute la petite
communauté près de 80 enfants
au quatrième jour evelyne a déjà recensé
plusieurs enfants morts vingt six morts
et trois fois plus de disparus mais
bizarrement evelyne n'en veut pas au
destin qui frappe si cruellement sa
crèche l'oeuvre de toute sa vie
aie aie aie aie avait les informant les
avait mis là ici bon
avec fait foi chrétienne on dira que le
bon dieu m'a tout donné
il a tout voté et que sont ses mains
soit bin je n'ai rien d'autre à dire
c'est la nature ces 2 qui arrive on ne
sait pas trop pourquoi mais c'est là si
evelyne prend ce drame avec fatalisme
en france en revanche 120 familles
vivent dans l'angoissé car la plupart de
ces enfants devaient bientôt être
adoptée
à plus de 7000 kilomètres de là depuis
quatre jours le téléphone n'arrête pas
de sonner chez éric et nathalie oui oui
merci
et il ya aussi le va et vient incessant
des amis qui apportent des cartons
remplis de médicaments ne passe pas deux
pas de nouvelles à l'heure où alors qu
il l a toujours pas de nouvelles c'est
gentil
tous sont inquiets pour leur petite
fille est erland une petite haïtienne de
trois ans et demi qu'ils viennent
d'adopter
elle doit rejoindre la famille dans
quelques mois depuis le séisme il ya
trois jours
ils sont sans nouvelles de leur fille
faut qu'on fasse gaffe de ne pas
mélanger avec les colis qui sont frères
dès l'annoncé de la catastrophe
le couple s'est organisée avec d'autres
familles adoptantes vous récoltez du
matériel de premiers soins des couches
du lait partie des d urgence aussi
[Musique]
compresse hockey des solutions de
désinfectant antibio ça c'est bien ça
des kits de faire c'est bien ça magali
vient elle aussi d'adopter un petit
haïtien
mais contrairement à éric et nathalie
elle a réussi à obtenir des nouvelles
mais bien que des méthodes eric travail
dans les ressources humaines
nathalie est agent culturel à la mairie
de son village
ensemble ils ont déjà une fille aliénor
neuf ans en 2008 il décide d'adopter
ils prennent à leur contact avec la
crèche notre dame de la nativité à port
au prince
[Musique]
voilà à quoi ressemblait la grande
maison où vivaient les enfants
ces images datent du mois d'avril
dernier elles ont été tournées par l'un
des membres de l'association notre dame
de la nativité n'est pas à proprement
parler un orphelinat
ici on appelle cela une crèche car tous
ces enfants voient régulièrement leurs
parents biologiques
ils les ont confiés à cette association
dans l'espoir qu'il soit un jour adopté
les vrais parents eux n'ont pas les
moyens de subvenir à leurs besoins
la crèche est financé en grande partie
par les familles françaises
[Musique]
grâce aux dons les enfants vont à
l'école ils sont nourris boivent de
l'eau purifiée et un médecin vient même
leur rendre visite régulièrement
eric et nathalie était en haïti la
semaine dernière pour régler les ultimes
formalités avant la venue de la petite
enfance le lien d'adoption entre parents
adoptants et et enfants il est très fort
il n'est pas virtuel c'est ce sont nos
enfants on les a vues les a touchées on
est tous allés les voir on les a eues
sur nos bras on les a embrassés on a on
a ressenti la chaleur de leur peau on a
vu leur regard donc oui bien sûr c'est
nos enfants mais bien sûr si nos enfants
rosicky
on a qu'une dizaine de noms d'enfants
prononcer aujourd'hui de façon certaine
envie et tous les autres c'est
l'interrogation lorsque ben on arrive à
trois jours du séisme
donc c'est très bien que c'est bientôt
les destins sont jetés pour tout le
monde
et
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce vendredi à port-au-prince à la crèche
notre dame de la nativité
les secours ne sont toujours pas arrivés
à l'heure et vine essaie de soigner les
enfants comme elle le peut elle
improvise un coin d'hôpital sur un bout
de trottoir
cette petite fille souffre d'une plaie
profonde au niveau de la cuisse pour la
soigner
francesca une simple aide soignante qui
a tout de suite proposé ses services
après la catastrophe
[Musique]
depuis elles veillent jour et nuit sur
les petits blessés
elle doit faire des miracles avec les
quelques compresse sauvées des décombres
pas d'antibiotiques pas d'anti douleurs
et surtout pas de désinfectant au milieu
de toute cette souffrance
il ya quand même des bonnes nouvelles et
ce terreau landes c'est la petite fille
que vont adopter eric et nathalie la
famille marseillaise ils viennent juste
d'être averti qu'elle est en vie pour
eric et nathalie c'est évidemment un
immense soulagement
mais cette tragédie risque fort de
retarder l'arrivée de leur enfant en
france car à port-au-prince leur dossier
d'adoption est enterrée sous des tonnes
de gravats
une situation qui inquiète
particulièrement evelyne la directrice
de la crèche
parce que
désosser au ministère de la justice on
parlait de l'iss
ministère de l'intérieur tout perdu donc
c'était une situation qui est très
alarmante
[Musique]
ce soir il vient de se produire une
énième secousse evelyne et ses petits
haïtiens s'apprêtent à passer leur
cinquième nuit dans la rue
[Applaudissements]
ouais
à
c'était
[Musique]
j'avais tout seul
[Applaudissements]
j'avais tout ça